My name is Mike Rosen and today
I'm going to tell you about a problem I see
as one of the really great problems today
in biology. And that is how eukaryotic cells are
organized on micron length scales.
Now I'll begin by telling you that eukaryotic cells
are organized across a huge range of length scales.
And the organization of individual atoms and protein
molecules to the assembly of those proteins into larger
and larger complexes, to the organization of those
complexes into distinct subcellular compartments,
out to membrane bound organelles in cells, out to
structures that consist of the entire length of the cell.
What I'll propose to you is that we understand the
organization on the shortest and longest length scales
quite well. So on the shortest scales, we understand a great
deal about how macromolecules function through
decades of structural biology and biophysical studies.
On the longer length scales, we understand through
cell biological studies that many of the membrane bound
compartments of the cell, for example, the nucleus,
the endoplasmic reticulum, golgi apparatus, the mitochondria,
all of those are very well understood in terms of their structures
and functions. However, there's an intermediate length
scale. Roughly 100 nm to 1 micron, on which we understand
the organization much, much, much more poorly.
Because there are in cells many structures of this
size that are not bound by membranes, that consist of
tens of thousands to hundreds of thousands of
individual macromolecules that are involved in many distinct
areas of biology. Now I'm just showing a short of panel of
those, a representative panel of those structures here.
So, for example, there are some structures, the JUNQ
and the IPOD structures that are involved in protein
quality control. There are structures in the nucleus called
PML nuclear bodies that are involved in DNA repair.
There are puncta of various metabolic enzymes that
have been observed in yeast and higher eukaryotes
that are believed to be involved in controlling metabolism.
There are puncta of numerous signaling molecules,
such as the disheveled protein here, that are involved
somehow in mediating signaling activities. There are RNA
granules of various flavors, for example, these stress
granules which are involved in translational control.
There are also numerous structures that exist in
the domain of the nucleus that are involved in organizing
of chromatin, which are believed to play an important role
in gene regulation. So these micron sized membrane-less
structures are found really throughout all of eukaryotic
biology. But we understand very little about their functions.
We understand a lot about the individual molecules that
control -- that are contained within these structures,
but we don't understand why those molecules, or how
those molecules are brought together into these micron
sized structures to impart new functionality to cells.
It turns out that there are also a number of potentially
analogous structures that are two-dimensional, that is
clusters of proteins on membranes. And those again
are important in very larges swathes of biology, and I've
just listed a few here. The immunological synapse, focal
adhesions, invadopodia structures; the initiation of
invadopodia structures are involved in T-cell activation
cell migration, tumor metastasis. And again, like the
three-dimensional equivalences, we know very little about
the nature of these structures and their functions in cells.
So, there are a series I think of fairly discrete questions
that we would really like to know about these structures.
To fill in the gap between macromolecular understanding
and membrane-bound structure understanding. So
first, what is the physical nature of the structure?
What are they? What are the molecules that compose them?
How are those held together to give a discrete structure?
What are their biochemical and cellular functions
of these cellular structures? And sort of to corollary
questions, how do the physical properties dictate the
biochemical and cellular functions? And finally, how
can the physical properties, and thus functions,
be controlled by cells to organize various biological processes?
So, these I think are fairly straightforward set of questions
but they're all very difficult questions. Let me spend a few
minutes explaining to you some of the challenges and
understanding them. And I think a lot of those challenges can
be illustrated by comparing a macromolecular assembly,
even a very large one like the eukaryotic ribosome, shown
here, to let's say a generic cellular punctum, these micron
sized membrane-less structures. So one of the first points
of comparison that one can make is the size.
So, even the eukaryotic ribosome, which is a gigantic
macromolecular machine, when you really scale it
to the size of one of these cellular puncta, it's miniscule.
So this is the size of a 25nm ribosome would be
compared to a 1 micron in diameter cellular punctum.
Perhaps even more importantly, though. Not only are these
much, much smaller, but the size of a macromolecular
complex is fixed by the components that compose it.
Whereas these cellular puncta, the sizes are highly
variable, sometimes they'll be small in cells, sometimes
they'll be large. They can transition from large to small
in response to different perturbations. Let me take the
ribosome back up to an unrealistic size to make my
additional comparisons. The composition is also very
different, macromolecular complexes are usually of
fixed stoichiometry such that there's always one copy
of this protein and one copy of that RNA. However,
the composition of these cellular puncta is highly
variable, molecules go in and out of them, some molecules
stay, some molecules go. They also are very different
to the level of structure, so macromolecular complexes are
stereochemically defined across their entire length. So
if I know where this amino acid is at one end, I know
the organization of that amino acid at the other end
of the molecule. However, these cellular puncta are almost
certainly not defined over their entire lengths. In fact,
we don't know on which length scales they are stereochemically
defined, and over what scale that definition decreases
as one moves out. They also are very different in
terms of dynamics. Much biochemistry of macromolecular
machines is governed by fluctuations on microsecond
and millisecond timescales. Whereas in these cellular
structures, yes the molecules within them move on those
timescales, but the molecules also move within these
structures and also between these structures and the
surrounding media on timescales that are much longer,
seconds to minutes. And frankly, it's really unclear at this
point which of those timescales of fluctuations are most
important to the function of these structures.
And finally, I think one of the most important issues
is function. So we know that macromolecular machines
function according to the domains that compose them.
Whereas, it's really unclear in these cellular structures
what functionality can be specifically ascribed to the
assembly itself and is distinct from the function of the
individual proteins within them. What does it mean to
organize them into this much, much larger structure?
We simply don't know at this point.
And finally, regulation, we know that macromolecular
machines are regulated often by alterations between
discrete configurations, inactive state and the active
state. However, because we don't understand the functions
of these cellular structures, it's unclear really what
should be controlled. What should we be looking for
to understand how function is altered by cellular
processes? Now, because of all of these difficulties
we really need new conceptual frameworks and new
experimental tools to understand these micron-sized
membrane-less cellular structures. Now I'm going to tell you
over the next few minutes a little bit about some ideas
that I and others in the field have had about this.
So, there are a couple of potential frameworks, conceptual
frameworks that derive from polymer science and soft
matter physics that may play some role here. And
one of them is this idea of polymerization, because
most simply, if you think, how do you make a big structure
from a bunch of little structures, the little structures may
just polymerize to make something much larger.
And when those assembling structures are multivalent,
systems can undergo what's called a cell gel phase
transition, such that in low fractional binding,
one gets distribution of small complexes. However,
as fractional binding goes up, there's a very sharp
line beyond which the system becomes capable of
assembling into huge macromolecular assemblies.
And it's possible then, that this soft gel transition
or polymerization in general, may contribute to these
micron sized structures. Another idea that's been
put forward recently is this notion of phase separations.
So I'm sure everyone's familiar if you mix oil and
water together and you shake them up, you can get these
little oil droplets that will float around in aqueous solution.
Well, it turns out, macromolecules, proteins and RNA,
in particular, can also do this. And in fact, as a system
polymerizes, as proteins polymerize they become less
soluble, they become more able to undergo this
kind of phase separation to produce concentrated
protein droplets, for example, in aqueous solution.
So again, it's been proposed that some kind of
phase separation may underlie many of these cellular
structures. I'm sure though, that with more thought and
more experiments, there are other conceptual frameworks
that also could be brought to understand these cellular
structures. In terms of tools, the tools that are used
to study macromolecular structures, x-ray crystallography,
NMR, electron microscopy, are really best to describe
discrete entities or fluctuations between discrete
conformational states. However, as I told you these cellular
structures are almost certainly not discrete entities.
And so we need new tools that will describe them as
distributions of structures, distributions of stoichiometries.
And probably also tools that will allow us to assess and
perturb the material properties, which may play a role in
the functions. And of course we need ways of relating
these properties to the individual macromolecular interactions
that govern their formation. In terms of function,
often in the fields of biophysics and cell biology,
biochemistry of purified components is used to understand
mechanistically, the functions of individual molecules
or individual entities. The problem is that most of these
cellular structures, in fact, can't be purified. And so we
need then ways of characterizing their biochemical
properties in situ, or to reconstitute these structures
from their individual parts. And perhaps most perplexing
at this point is, we need ways of directly interrogating
the functions of the assemblies themselves.
Again, as distinct from the components that compose them.
And we really need new experimental approaches to
address that issue of assembly. And finally, we need new
theoretical descriptions of these structures. And it may be
possible to take theories that exist already in polymer
science, colloid science, material science, and apply
them to biology. But an important distinction between
biology and these other physical sciences is that biology
is almost always held out away from equilibrium by the
consumption of energy through ATP hydrolysis. And so
one then needs to take these equilibrium studies and
apply them to biology by incorporating this idea of
systems away from equilibrium. And I know there are studies
of active matter in the soft matter physics world that
may very well be applicable to biology. So, let me just conclude
by coming back to what we would like to know in these systems.
What are they? What do they do? How does what
they are dictate what they do? And how can biology
control all of this to mediate various biological processes?
So I think if over say, the next decade, we can understand
all of these questions, we'll fill in this interesting and
confusing gap between macromolecules on one end
and membrane-bound organelles on the other, and
give us a thorough across scales understanding of biology.
So hopefully I've inspired some of you to think about this
problem and hopefully you, over the course of your career,
will be able to answer many of these questions.
Thank you.